hey why Oriole companies such a hot
hacking top you know it's a really
interesting question and that's sort of
what what got me interested in the first
because you think about the big hacking
attacks that we've heard about you know
banks and retailers you get that cut you
know for criminals they get that instant
payback and with energy that doesn't
really seem to be here there but there
are a couple things to remember one is
you know energy is traded you know you
could get some kind of edge from from
snooping that way also obviously for
competitors any kind of business
information but then there's this other
component and it seems like most of
these attacks are coming from foreign
nation states doing industrial espionage
which could be used to actually you know
like in a like a cyberwar kind of a way
to actually create a physical damage by
infiltrating like I'm going to shut down
the utility or a nuclear reactor or
something along those lines is that for
the implication that's the fear yeah so
how prepared our energy companies I mean
we know the retailer's were not the
government is also still struggling with
hackers I'm it's a huge issue and it
certainly you know all the cyber
security companies are very eager to try
to sell them more of these services to
help them prepare you know it's
interesting if you know it's unintended
consequences a lot of these physical
infrastructure systems were brought
online since the the big blackout in in
on the east coast to try to you know
improve reliability and what people
didn't really anticipate was once you
connect everything that that creates
this new what they call a tax office so
how much do they have to spend so far
have they spent so far it's getting its
billions a year and and that's number
that's supposed to increase is there
some sort of ham don't know clues that
we can find in terms of the types of
companies they hack is at us-based is it
kind of different country basis the big
guys small guys is there a theme here
well I mean a lot of the attacks it
depends kind of whose side you're on but
they sort of point to you know the usual
suspects the countries that you would
guess but you know it goes both ways in
a lot of ways you know let's not forget
so the Snowden documents one of the
things that they showed was there was a
big controversy a few years ago that one
of the targets for the NSA had been
Petrobras hmm right okay so it doesn't
necessarily mean it's Russia or China
and a lot of its and last year a big
attack was
that Russian hackers were allegedly
looking into northern North American
utilities basically trying to infiltrate
the system so that they might be able to
take control later on and then you
mentioned utility so is that more aware
of the risk is or these drillers what
kind of energy companies are getting hit
the hardest it's the whole range oh yeah
I mean all these things are online
they're all run by computers and that's
an opportunity where you could have
physical damage from a cyberattack and
my sister their cost basis I mean you
know that oil companies are dealing with
the lowered oil price and struggling
there and their capex they're already
cutting like how much an incremental
earnings bummer will piss pee for oil
companies well that's actually probably
one of the reasons why the industry has
been may be slower to adapt then you
know then finance for example is there
hasn't been that sort of immediate huge
wake-up call and they're also they all
have customers who are banging down
their doors demanding it like you would
when it's you know it's credit card or a
bank so that's you know one of those
things that that sort of has the cyber
security industry clamoring to you know
before it's too late let's wake up to
the sound like don't wait for the big
catalyst get in